on va en prendre mais dans la limite du
raisonnable est de savoir qui vient chez
nous il ya des gens là dedans qui parle
ni anglais ni français va falloir et des
jeux mon avenir de montréal je me
prendre un billet je m'ennuierais syrie
je me lève vraiment la brède abdellah
ben c'est comme ça on apprendrait à
québec puis me vengerai c'est
merveilleux andré savoie candidat dans
avignon la mitis matane matapédia
bonsoir à vous trois est ce qu'ils
continuent la campagne lui ou c'est
vraiment on est sur la frange la bad à
bord va falloir en moyenne traduction
insulter ou est ce que c'est ce qu'on a
donné aux candidats conservateurs la
liberté sur ce dossier de dire à peu
près n'importe qui ça me tenait s'est
penché sur ce dossier là de toute façon
on a perdu un candidat conservateur à
terre-neuve aujourd'hui parce qu'il
pensait que les noirs de vous regarder
des films ou des noirs comme ça il y
aurait plus de noirs dans les films mais
on continue et il ya un problème de
filtrage de kant très bien mais sur la
question des migrants ne saura plus
quand même pas besoin de déclaration
comme ça même s'il parle la sécurité
mais aussi fait écho aux craintes que
plusieurs canadiens
et pas besoin de sol non elle et on
avait l'impression que c'était pas assez
qu'on était revenu dans l'économie le
début du global erp s'en vient je lui
dis bonne nouvelle sur le budget les
surplus au début de semaine je pense que
c'est maintenant qu'on va retomber dans
l'ornière de la crise des réfugiés
peut-être que ça ne lui est pas aussi
mal servis qu'on ne le pensait on
regarde les sondages qui effectivement
une frange de la population qui trouve
que le canadien fait suffisamment
actuellement ça veut pas dire par contre
que le candidat que peuvent commencer du
côté conservateur à se laisser aller
les syriens sont mûrs mais comparer le
prix si c'est ça la commanderie mettrait
au chômage peut-être d'aller en syrie et
d'avoir été la bonne
décision de la cour d'appel fédérale
aujourd'hui sur le niqab qui confirme le
premier jugement de la cour fédérale
c'est à dire une femme a le droit de
porter le niqab lors de la cérémonie
d'assermentation selon la réglementation
actuelle dans la campagne est ce que
vous attendez à ce que sont henri en
temps de parler chantal goya j'ai dû
faire pour nom du bloc québécois qui
réclame que le gouvernement fédéral
c'est en alliant cour suprême peut-être
qu'à mentir ça aurait dû regarder
l'historique de cette cause là parce
qu'on est pas ici devant une cause qui
touche la charte des droits on est ici
devant un jugement en première instance
et encore aujourd'hui où la cour
fédérale dit vous avez un problème parce
que les directives ministérielles
contredit le règlement et vous avez pas
changer le règlement et une directive
ministérielle il faut enlever le micam
pour être assermenté pèse moins lourd
que le règlement qui dit le juge de
citoyenneté doit donner le plus de
latitude possible de vos expressions
religieuses ou autres des des gens qui
autrement dit le gouvernement n'a pas le
droit de l'empêcher dans l'état non mais
y aurait pu changer de règlement du
repos et il ya un projet de loi déposé
en jeu soit défonçant des derniers jours
de la session alors qu'on savait qu'il
ne pouvait pas être adoptée alors c'est
clair que le parti conservateur veut se
servir de ça il n'y aurait pas
conscience qu'elles se servir de sa wii
mesure des prochains jours et je suppose
que ça lui reviendra pas un peu dans la
figure parce que à la fin ce projet de
loi là était une tentative tellement
claire va essayer de manipuler l'opinion
publique le dernier jour de la session
quand on sait qu'ils reviendront pas
avant l'élection c'est un peu fort de
café
un amendement à un règlement ça se fait
par arrêt du conseil des ministres ça
prend quelques minutes à modifier le ch
aura pas de vote au parlement si le
gouvernement prend cette cause là au
sérieux il pouvait l'avoir fait il ya
des mois on a volontairement était en
appel en espérant que ça tombe mono la
campagne il est alors divisée pour avoir
la controverse qui vient avec des bébés
nouveau se présente en champion de la
citoyenneté à visage découvert alors
qu'on aurait pu régler ça il ya
maintenant plusieurs mois très bien
parlons de sentiers on n'a pas parlé de
ça encore on va parler des personnes
âgées dans une seconde mais monsieur
mulcair en troll qui dit moi je veux
5000 médecins de 5000 médecins de plus
au canada
je veux des cliniques de plus au canada
c'est une compétence provinciale comment
peut-il faire ce que ça tient la route
michel
il pleut il peut donner de l'argent mais
c'est tout ce qu'il peut faire
vous êtes conditionnel c'est ce qui
semble e10 conditionnelle à la fin dans
l'état où ils sont ils des finances des
brevets je pense les brouillons
d'accepter la mais elle a fait tout ce
qu'il peut faire c'est donner l'argent
c'est pas sa compétence c'est pas sa
décision puis des médecins ont aussi au
québec ça ne se crée pas de jour au
lendemain alors vous vous venez le
médecin plus ça m'apprend de 7 ans
arrivé dans le système afin qu' on ne
peut pas voir les gens portent l'oreille
parce que c'est un problème très
franchement c'est pas au gouvernement
fédéral de n'importe quel parti de s'en
aller des provinces et aux facultés de
médecine aussi combien vous devriez
formé de médecins de plus monsieur marc
ayrault dit qu'il allait maintenir
l'augmentation actuelle du transfert
canadien en santé qui doit ralentir
l'année prochaine mais apprécié y'a pas
grand chose qui peut dire il peut pas
s'en aller dire voici combien de
médecins puis je vous donne l'argent il
peut pas y avoir des médecins federal
des bourses du millénaire pour des
médecins qu'on veut a ajouté
alors moi j'ai l'impression que c'est
une façon de réussir à dire de mon santé
santé santé mais je trouve que c'est pas
très bien ficelé alex sur la santé
écoutez on est du côté fédéral toujours
à la recherche de politique et motti qui
vont toucher les gens solidement fédéral
c'est souvent assez clair assez loin des
gens alors que la santé ça touche les
gens l'éducation ça touche les gens
malheureusement cette compétence
provinciale donc on donne de l'argent
puis on essaie de mettre des chiffres
donc les gens soient au moins attentifs
à la promesse qui vont avec les libéraux
au fond en fonte avec la formation
professionnelle de la main d'oeuvre
aujourd'hui on parle tour d'entente avec
les provinces
ce jour le mot clé en partenariat avec
les provinces mais ceci dit on donne de
l'argent et on espère que ça se produise
mais il ya toujours un côté très
conditionneur et ses promesses les eaux
fédérales l'entente que parlementaire
conclus avec les provinces et yonne plus
que dix ans maintenant
après le québec tout le monde était nul
de fer papa pour réduire les temps
d'attenté toujours très franchement il
ya beaucoup d'argent qui sont allés en
santé il eu certainement des
améliorations mais on n'a jamais
vraiment atteint les objectifs fixés par
le fédéral c'est une complexe
son nom oui le fédéral est pas écrit le
ministère fédéral de la santé il faut
équiper près de vérifier comment ça
marche dans la micro économie du système
de santé les parties courtisent ou si
c'est un classique les personnes âgées
lors il ya eu des annonces aujourd'hui
chez les libéraux d'autres les
conservateurs ont su mettre de l'argent
alors ça tient la route
tu es depuis deux semaines là c'est de
la surenchère pour les aînés le même le
npd que vous avez pas nommé dimanche à
1.8 milliard je pense d'annonce pour les
aînés on est une population canada qui
vieillit c'est une population qui vote
contrairement aux jeunes votent en plus
grandes proportions
on a besoin de cet électorat là dans
tous les partis politiques pour être
capable de l'emporter
alors on se préoccupe énormément de leur
soeur on leur promet toutes sortes de
choses pour qu'en bout de ligne on
puisse être capables de sceller leur
voie était donc lieu à la marge des
différences de solutions city venant
préconisent les crédits d'impôt et adore
les crédits d'impôt qui est à
complexifier le système d'impôt canada
rouvel mollet voilà les libéraux plein
pdc supplément de revenu garanti qui
vont être qu'ils vont être bonifié en
bout de piste qu'on veut c'est que les
aînés on peut s'attirer leur attention
même si les jeunes beautés autant dans
les mêmes proportions que les personnes
de plus que 55 ans on annonce que des
bourses d'études et dans une élection du
millénaire il a pensé mais dans une
élection qui va être serré ça fait une
différence qui va voter et ce sont les
électeurs les plus assidus donc tous les
partis veulent et à moi mais en même
temps ça prouve aussi un peu de ce type
de d'un an qu'on va voir d'ici la fin de
la campagne du clientélisme les choses
extrêmement ciblées extrêmement pointus
parce qu'on a pas énormément d'argent
dans d'immenses si on peut aller
chercher ces électeurs là voici quelque
chose qui sera important au regard des
sondages de ce matin le rendrait à 30
ans parce que le npd à l'égard de riquet
quand même méga programmes qu'on veut
mettre sur pied avec les provinces
cayzac on avoir un chèque mais sinon
effectivement y'a rien qui nous a
frappés comme annonce engagement
promesses en fait je pense m'être des
modèles y at-il quelque chose d'immobile
action sur l'infrastructure
né mais jeudi il ya beaucoup plus
d'argent alors moi je trouve que les
libéraux en fait un assez bon travail
pour neutraliser l'impact des
prestations pour enfants qui sont
arrivés en juillet en annonçant une
prestation rhmani les experts en matière
de revenu familial vont vous dire
qu'effectivement à terme ça permettra un
nombre assez important de familles de
sortir de la pauvreté c'est une
récitation de magny et plus ciblées mais
c'est bien qui fait que les gens vont
s'asseoir et à s'entendre ça c'est ya
rien de radical fouad attar
ce qui revient je vais conclure là
dessus on va y revenir plusieurs fois
mais ce qui revient à la personnalité
des chefs peuvent peuvent-ils induire de
la confiance quand il parle aux
canadiens je manque un peu depuis le
début de la campagne ce cru ça a bougé
beaucoup dans votre esprit on est à peu
près où on était il ya cinq semaines
chaque alex à bouger un peu je pense que
justin trudeau partait de plus loin et
il sait ramener au niveau des deux
autres mais depuis une semaine et demie
de jos estime yann et on regarde les
sondages ce qui ferait le meilleur
premier ministre qui a hacké vais vous
le plus confiance pour gérer l'économie
ils sont au coude à coude le 7 août dans
la marge d'erreur donc même quand on
creuse les sondages au delà des
intentions de vote ça se ressemble
beaucoup d'un parti à l'autre alors la
difficulté à voir qu'ils vont réussir à
la toute fin à arriver ou premier au fil
d'arrivée parce que c'est vraiment très
série reste encore du temps il reste
l'équivalent de paris portant des gros
dossiers les migrants oui récession et
c'est patrice moi j'ai couvert des
sélections ont rien bouger pendant une
campagne électorale ont découvert une en
ontario où on a fini à la fin avec deux
sièges qui avaient changé de mains ça
arrive alors sur la symétrie qu'au
fédéral je le sais pas ce que ça va
donner je dis pas qu'on est là il reste
route mais ça peut arriver que tout le
monde reste sur ses positions pilot
envers la mathématique que de ce qui
sortira des urnes mais on est dans une
situation complètement inédite il ya
trois grands participent aux deux et
trois grands partis qui sont sous la
coupe de l'intérieur de la marge
d'erreur des sondages ça on n'a pas la
recette pour cent au canada on n'a
jamais vu ça alors ce que ça va sortir
ce que c'est
si ça reste comme ça bien jeu ce qui va
sortir des urnes faut être bon et
libéraux et néo démocrates s'étaient
parlé comme il en a été question il ya
trois ou quatre ans monsieur harper
serait déjà en train de prévoir sa
retraite at-il pas l'euro après parce
que la daf
parce que le gouvernent le désir de
changement clubs aussi forts donc il
faut plus pour nous est que cette phase
finale c'est quand ils allaient changer
quelque chose pour le npd et les
libéraux les vases communicants des
élagueurs à la toute fin on peut
supposer que j'allais calais calais
qu'on va vous laisser aller quelques
jours et messieurs vous devenez papa oui
alors félicitations à la maman oui les
chances à ce frère ça se fait lol oui
même avoir une perte de vue un peu oui
mais vous allez revenir un peu plus
fatigué que je me suis mais je dirige
ont peut-être un peu plus un peu plus
impatients oui peut-être
après trois heures de sommeil à dieu
tout le monde ali